let's get a check of campaign 2020
nearly a week after dropping out of the
presidential race senator Bernie Sanders
has endorsed former Vice President Joe
Biden the two men appeared on a live
stream yesterday no handshake no rally
and Sanders pledged to help Biden defeat
President Trump in November political
correspondent ed O'Keefe joins us from
Washington heed good morning this is
unity pretty early for the Democrats
what does it mean for the Democratic
Party going forward
it sure is Tony a big step towards party
unity to put this into perspective
Sanders is endorsement comes three
months earlier than the one he gave
Hillary Clinton four years ago and gives
Biden about 200 days now to take on
President Trump listen here to some of
what Sanders and Biden had to say I am
asking all Americans I'm asking every
Democrat I'm asking every independent
I'm asking a lot of Republicans to come
together in this campaign to support
your candidacy which I endorse I'm gonna
need you not just to win the campaign
but to govern Biden and Sanders say
they're forming task forces to discuss
issues like health care immigration and
climate change the former vice president
of course still faces a lot of
skepticism from younger liberal voters
who are weary of the Democratic
establishment and his career so the
Senators endorsement is designed to
bring his fiercely loyal supporters
under the Biden umbrella the former vice
president Gayle last night easily won
the Wisconsin primary as expected you
know and under normal circumstances that
would have been the lead story today but
you know things have not been normal for
quite some time that's why it's so
important to be reminded there is a very
important presidential campaign going on
2020 I think sometimes we lose sight of
that let's not do that well I appreciate
you pointing that out yes would you call
that yesterday would you call that a
full-throated endorsement what we heard
absolutely absolutely I mean look
they're confined to doing what you and I
do sitting here in our own homes and
talking to each other that may very well
be what campaign 2020 looks like between
now and November we'll see but
absolutely designed to be an explicit
endorsement and remove
I doubt that Sanders is now backing his
friend Joe Biden all right party unity
as Tony said coming early and now we
have conventions coming up - we shall
see thank you very much ed O'Keefe
really good to see you